(Music)
♫ Here we stand ♫
♫ Like an Adam and an Eve ♫
♫ Waterfalls ♫
♫ The Garden of Eden ♫
♫ Two fools in love ♫
♫ So beautiful and strong ♫
♫ Birds in the trees ♫
♫ Are smiling upon them ♫
♫ From the age of the dinosaurs ♫
♫ Cars would run on gasoline ♫
♫ Where? Where have they gone? ♫
♫ Now, there's nothing but flowers ♫
♫ This was a factory ♫
♫Now there are mountains and rivers ♫
♫ You got it, you got it ♫
♫ We caught a rattlesnake ♫
♫ Now we've got something for dinner ♫
♫ You got it, you got it ♫
♫ This was a parking lot ♫
♫ Now it's all covered with flowers ♫
♫ You got it, you got it ♫
♫ If this is paradise ♫
♫ I wish I had a lawnmower ♫
♫ You got it, you got it ♫
♫ This was a shopping mall ♫
♫ Now it's turned into corn field ♫
♫ You got it, you got it ♫
♫ Don't leave me stranded here ♫
♫ I can't get used to this lifestyle ♫
(Applause)
Thomas Dolby: David Byrne.